[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday we begin this half hour with
violent unrest in africa's most populous
country
demonstrators have stayed off the
streets of lagos nigeria this morning
after a brutal week
that saw government forces shoot and
kill protesters who were demonstrating
against police brutality
the shootings have triggered an
international outcry and a nationwide
movement for social change
deborah powder reports from johannesburg
[Applause]
the situation took a deadly turn this
week when soldiers opened fire on
demonstrators
killing at least 12 people they are
shooting
they are shooting the brutal suppression
of a peaceful demonstration
has only served to increase the anger of
nigerians
who continue to take to the streets
we're here because
we believe in what we're fighting for we
are here to defend
our unity over two weeks ago tens of
thousands of nigerians
began demanding the disbanding of the
controversial special anti-robbery squad
known as sars they are striking
similarities with the u.s
protests over the killing of george
floyd commentators are quick to point
out
that police brutality flourishes when
law enforcement protects the interests
of the powerful
once you're not a community resource and
you have authority over people
and you have no accountability
structures
you then create the environment where
bad people who do bad things with that
power
nigerian president muhammadu buhari
promised to disband sars over a week ago
but it was too late fed up with years of
corruption and a lack of accountability
protesters have turned this into a far
bigger crisis
for his government police brutality is
not the only issue fuelling
anti-government sentiment the misuse of
emergency covert relief funds
and a stagnant economy crippled by the
pandemic
have become major targets for popular
anger deborah powder cbs news
johannesburg south africa